Dumba has it there for the coyotes moves it
back in a sharp angle shot knocked down and
covered by gustofson finished second in the NCA
in scoring only Adam fan Tilly who we saw last
week in Columbus had more points last year as a
Collegiate player Middleton bumped in the corner
McBain centers and a quick shot by schaltz
caught iron in the front of the net and he's
a right-handed shot that's right on the tape and
he Gunther back for dery in the middle Keller in
the circle to the side of the net her foot goes
back to Keller Keller looking kerfoot scores left
alone down low in the zone and the power play
goal for Arizona has them in front one Zer wow
what a play by Clayton Keller takes the puck
back from Cur foot here and gets a little bit
of ice to the inside fakes a shot Guston bites
doesn't really bite on this shot but gets caugh
kind of lost in traffic and hits curo foot right
on the tape and he's able to slide that right in
the empty net guys are coming back from injury and
that's important and that's good Anthony but again
it takes a little bit of time guys haven't played
a whole lot unfortunately the wild don't have a
whole lot of time kesserling sends it across and
buuk dead scores and the wild find themselves down
two Marco maroon just tried to throw the puck out
front Felino left the Zone a little bit too early
and the puck pass was behind him and a nice little
little play there and buestad gets all of that
that's his first goal in 16 or 17 games Nick buad
knocks it right past guson Capri able to knock it
away from Gunther kering there to pick it up for
the coyotes he reverses out from behind his own
net Gunther goes cross ice with it here's kerfoot
moving in kerfoot fires off the post Jersy did a
good job of just really not hooking doam down and
there was a big Collision there Pino able to kick
it ahead for Minnesota 22 left in the power play
as bues dead got it to melli now zooker sends
it across for KRA Crow centers and they score it
deflects in past Guston and it's 30 Arizona kuss
with a puck going down the back door right here
and looks to me like he's trying to make the pass
to buad and I do not believe buestad gets his
stick on that one goes right off of mm's back
foot and into the empty net the did
catch buad stick before mm's foot
he'll probably get credit for the goal
clearing attempt knocked down by Faber
at the line zuk Carell moves down the
boards centered Ericson e a tip saved by
Ingram zuk Carell moves in weights
tried to go back to Baldi a chance
for capris off Saved by Ingram and
that will bring us to the end of the
period back to five on five Hartman at center ice
Keller Moves In for the
coyotes Keller Works around
gagoski here's Keller out of the corner fires and
scores there was a lot of traffic in front of
Guston the wild consider challenging this for
golender interference you can see Keller here
moving to open ice and then gets a little bit
of space here guson trying to find the puck
looked to me like he might have had some his
feet as his Puck enters the I don't think
he had anything I don't think there was any
contact there with Gus and he was inside the
paint unless he caught the stick in his skates
prior to this shot it's hard to tell oh boy like
looked to me like the puck had probably crossed
the goal line Anthony before his stick un tangled
up for Hartman and across to Baldi Hartman one of
the hottest scorers in the lineup with a wild
turn over here bues that in cuts to the slot a
shot and a save by Guston well Gus after the
Arizona has made it four nothings made three
or four great saves a couple on the p on the
recent power play looking much sharper here
zooker cross I pass buad fires and scores
and that's the hattrick for Nick buad the
former wild Winger what a night for him coming
back into the building that was his home home
building this summer after coming off of a a
great campaign where he scored 17 goals nice
little short side roof right there that's the
shot that righy like to make if you get just a
little bit of space and yeah no surprise John
hind juggling up his lines right now deciding
he's going to play the guys that probably want to
play hard we'll see how many guys get a chance to
get back on the ice bber shot save capriso on the
rebound and another stop by Ingram loses schaltz
whps it down for Maroon the rapper on try saved
by Ingram rebound is loose still no whistle and
finally cleared try to go off the board to gagasi
he just does hold the Zone duain fights through a
check behind the net out to mermis mermis goes
back to Duan his shot got through save Ingram
rebound they score Patrick maroon out front
and the Wild on the board halfway through the
second well that's a working man's goal right
there we showed who just had a great scoring
chance finds himself right in the paint gives
the defender a little shot there from behind
and gets rewarded with a loose Puck sitting
there right now and looks up to the heavens
great job there by Dam just throwing the pock
into the paint that maroon possibly could have
got caught for called for a cross check there but
a little bit of a push from behind and looks like
this one might get overturned yeah it's uh and I
actually I think that's why Patrick maroon maybe
lifted his head right there because he had
known possibly that he threw the defenseman
into the goal tender he's probably looking at
the replay back there high probability that
this one gets called back Johnny Madden one a
few selki Trophies the assistant coach there
without Shier this is the play right here push
in there from behind goer not unable to play his
position after coach's challenge video review
it was determined that the Minnesota player
pushes the Arizona player into the goalie we
have made it very very difficult for the Wilds
game regardless how many fors they have of any
flow Merl to favor centers and Hartman denied
Ingram got a skate on it the wild did a nice
job of getting through the neutral zone and
hanging on to procs and if the wild are going
to want to have they're going to have success
in the future and get some wins like where Joe
Hansson is right there this is where you're going
to need to control games because we got to break
away here break away the other way for Keller in
against blurry and he scores and 38 seconds into
the third it's 6-0 coyotes Clayton Keller's been
the most dangerous Arizona coyote 8 6 points
last year just Nifty Nifty little hands here
little fake shot brings it to his forehand and
lifts it right up over the the pad of Mark Andre
flurry coyotes scored three in the first
period and Minnesota never really got
much of a push going the coyotes Coast
to a 60 shutout here in St all tonight